what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness yes
that's correct that's correct before I
start let's hear from our
sponsor chances are you have been here
before the chaos in the markets oil and
stocks just when you thought it was safe
and interest rates were Rising new
threats come out of nowhere tensions are
boiling from Asia to Europe and
adaptation is the key here to
safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you definitely need some insurance Noble
gold Investments has been protecting
investors from disaster four years with
precious medals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven Safe
Haven shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3 oz silver American
virtue coin with its new IAS this month
if you open up your Noble gold
Investments Ira or for 401K rollover you
can claim your coin today remember
crisis is Brew portfolio's waiver but
gold insulate secure yourself against
threats go to noblegold investments.com
now that's noblegold investments.com the
only gold company that I
trust okay guys um also before we start
we have a bunch of new merch so make
sure that you check it out okay so my
first topic today as you guys know I
have the hashtag ieem Challenge on
Twitter which by the way you guys can
get a sweatshirt that says # I deem this
outfit inappropriate and I recently saw
a plus-size model so my biggest issue
with the plus-size movement is that they
do not promote health and on top of that
they do not promote modesty I think as
young women it is important especially
if you have children that you are an
example of modesty for your children so
Ashley Graham is a wife and is a mother
and she recently posted this
[Music]
video
oh my God now again she's wearing the
modern women outfit so what what is the
Modern Woman outfit typically it's big
usually gold hoop earrings face full of
makeup and very provocative clothing you
know I I just kind of I see this picture
and I think what is the point if you're
half naked what is the point of wearing
a see-through top and my thing is when
you have children you are supposed to
act and move differently when you are a
wife and a mother and so many times
women think they can act like they are a
young woman in her teens or early 20s
that's a great accomplishment girl
amazing if we're being honest guys you
get a little bit of leeway when you're
younger but when you're older it just
starts to look silly what happened to
the wives and mothers that we could look
up to as Role Models All these ghosts
all these ghosts and I still can't find
a boo I don't see any in the media I see
very few online and now we celebrate
being overweight and also being
provocative these are not things that we
should celebrate so I gave this an I
deem a # IEM inappropriate for being a
wife and a mother now I I like to have
these conversations on Twitter a lot of
times people think that I am
trolling
yeah uh well I'm just not sure about
that and I will say 90% of the time I I
do use humor sometimes I make jokes but
this is a serious conversation you know
what is appropriate when you are married
why do married women need to be naked so
freaking bad I I don't understand it it
feels really good it feels so good and
this is a common response I get is it
wrong for moms and married women to want
to feel sexy or should they stay fully
clothed and act like a virgin Mary at
all times genuinely asking everybody has
moment I am not here to judge anybody I
am not here to act like I am better than
anybody but rather point out where we
want to move as a society everybody has
moments but those moments should be for
your husband why do women need to take
these pictures and post them online is
my question why can't they just send
them to their husbands that's a good
question and the issue is you have grown
women seeking attention and validation
from other men and honestly guys it's
disgusting we we should not be doing
that as wives and mothers okay Alexander
yabara said this should be common
knowledge by now women use attention as
currency therefore the solution to all
of their problems the naive and Confused
one is to gather up as much attention as
they can in order to fill the void they
have within and the best tool that they
get to do that is their physique and you
know what's interesting guys I I've
noticed this trend and I I I am never
going to be the one that says appearance
is not important appearance is
definitely important but you get to see
what women value by what they spend
their money and their time on and some
women are so self-centered that they
have spent years looking in the mirror
taking selfies posing for the camera the
only thing that matters to them is
looking good and looks only go so deep
so many times I hear women talk talk
about femininity and talk about how
being feminine is about having a certain
look no the most feminine women that I
have met were not trendy they were not
fashionable femininity has nothing to do
with that bro what are you talking about
man femininity at its core is
selflessness it is serving your man your
community and the people around you that
is femininity oh it is not this over
Obsession that we have on the latest
fashion TR makeup Beauty and promiscuity
and the problem is you have all of these
influencers coming in telling women to
raise their price saying oh you are a
queen you deserve the world you are so
beautiful you were so amazing you were
so awesome but they they never tell them
to give and if you really do want to
raise your price as a woman that is the
best way to do it to figure out how to
give to the people around you it is not
to get a Fashion Makeover how many times
in movies have we seen that where women
just get a makeover and then they get
the guy or whatever but it it it shows
what our culture value beauty when
really the wives with the best outcomes
were they get to marry competitive
handsome successful men and they get to
stay married to them because so many
times women look at Kim Kardashian as a
w oh God Kim Kardashian got married
three times to high value men but what
does it matter if you can't keep the
marriage and we have so many wives and
sheep's clothing where they think that
because they have the ring and the title
that they are wives you are not a wife
until you serve your husband that is
what being a wife is and until modern
women learn to do that they do not get
wife status Sylvia says unfortunately
many women have no other ways to draw
attention to themselves because they
don't know how they will definitely have
their self-esteem lowed down I don't
agree with women in general they undress
to attract attention yeah and this is
wrong it's wrong and it's very selfish
because you guys have kids man [__] them
kids bro and that that's why I I always
say I deem this inappropriate for a wife
and a mother because guys it's just a
different level of stupid when you have
a child at some point it's not about you
at some point the attention is supposed
to go on your kid if if you want to I
don't know take those pictures take them
send them to your husband why must the
world see them okay so second topic
today I want to talk about another
phenomenon that I see in society so
there is a picture going around of a
woman who drew up a list of rewards to
encourage her husband to do chores for
her
no okay so this says sexual rewards
washes dishes equals hand job put away
look after the kids for a whole day
includes BJ feeding nappies putting the
bed Hooper house um touching F anyways
basically she's saying that if you do
the chores I will give you sex that is
not what a wife is and again this is why
I say there are many wives and sheep's
clothing that have never taught their
daughters how to be a wife and so what
we have is Generation after generation
after generation of women that are
selfish what is this scream it says I
want him to do something for me
therefore I am going to withhold sex to
get what I want relationships like that
do not work and honestly if I were God I
think men should sue for fraud I really
do I think men should be able to sue
their wives for fraud I don't think
that's how it works if they get married
thinking they're going to have sex and
then the woman just pulls one over and
has does this to them and guys this is
so emasculating to a guy this is men men
want you to want to be with them they
don't they don't want to you know how
mascula it is to provide and protect for
a woman only to have her belittle you in
this way and women think this is funny
that supposed to be funny no it's not
funny at all this is not funny it is not
cute it is the reason that I mean
honestly so many marriages are in the
[__] because and and I had this
thought I had this thought with born-
again virgins I I kind of make fun of
them a little bit where women um
basically do the they they sleep with a
guy and then come out and say oh now you
were waiting for marriage and I thought
about the only way that could work is if
it's on the guy's terms if it's on the
woman's terms that does not work men
need to be in control relationships do
not work when the women are steering
them and controlling them and so many
guys just let women it's actually so sad
to see so many guys just let women
control their relationships they go on
dates where she wants to go the house is
decorated the way she
wants they they do want they do in their
free time what she wants to do it's
never what he wants it's always what she
wants and and and these guys you know
sometimes guys I don't feel bad for you
because you guys make brats you because
you're too weeny to stand up for
yourself so sorry there's nothing I can
do now I I totally understand the court
system okay I I totally do so I know
it's not that simple I do but at some
point you guys are creating monsters
because you give these chicks whatever
they want and 90% of them don't deserve
deserve it I mean really like what are
chicks doing I was asking around guys I
know how much they spend on their women
and they said I think they said like two
grand a month that was like the
consensus or I think it was like a 10K a
year for a girlfriend and I really
thought to myself I'm like what an earth
is this girl doing to get $10,000 a year
that's like a part-time job I thought to
myself like what but this is the problem
even on first dates I thought about this
I really think women should spend money
on men you can say that again I don't
even really like traditionalism because
traditionalism just puts women on a
pedestal what is that supposed to mean I
mean the man must take you on a date he
has to plan it he has to do everything
when women really are not happy unless
they're doing for you that is the only
way I have seen relationships work when
the woman is doing for the man and we
studied Melania as a case study
right where Melania she came into the
relationship she moved into his house
she said I don't try to change him I
just try to make his life better that's
what you were supposed to do as a woman
you know Adam was just fine without Eve
in the garden and all of this all of
this stuff I hear it's such nonsense and
I hear it from the right and the left it
just pisses me off because it's just
pandering to no end you know even the
idea that men need women men do not need
women oh
[Music]
okay men do not Jesus did not get
married he did not have kids he didn't
do it some of the greatest Saints did
not get married and they did not have
kids women should not be rewarded with
marriage unless they deserve it they
should not be rewarded with men's time
and attention and guys we have we have
these women running around like brats I
just saw a woman have a full a grown
woman have a full-blown temper tantrum
in an airport I swear we both missed our
flight I missed my flight and so did she
and this woman just got on her back and
started screaming this is the craziest
thing I've ever
seeny
[Music]
now me I was upset I missed my flight
but I just ask all right when's the next
flight what else are you going to do but
you have these women that have no
emotional regulation and I and you ask
why well we have this society that puts
them on a freaking pedestal and says
they're so amazing and special and
awesome even I don't even guys I don't
even like this propaganda they throw
saying that the most selfless job in the
world is being a housewife really huh
what
oh okay that's the most selfless job in
the world I mean guys you get to stay at
home women Housewives today have easier
lives than most people had in all of
history it is not this crazy hard job if
it was you wouldn't pay a babysitter $15
an hour to watch your kids now I'm not
discounting the value of it I think
women should stay home with their
children but what I'm discounting is you
guys's freaking female narcissism left
and right it drives me freaking crazy
and then I'm the bad guy for pointing
out no no that's not true because I I
don't go with the Pander so many of you
guys Pander to your wives you Pander to
your girlfriends and I'm just sick of
seeing it because this is what you get
this is what pandering gives you and
then you're going to get in these crazy
situations and you wonder why they're
you're in them well Pander for a
lifetime that's what you get so what do
you want to do now so Brook says ladies
just have sex with your husband stop
attaching strings to it trust me the sex
is much better when you remove the
strings yes Captain horror men and women
enjoys sex any woman who says she
doesn't is lying or her husband isn't
that great in bed sex is a shared
intimate bonding element of marriage
whoever does this shouldn't be married
let my husband tell me he's not having
sex with me if I don't do the chores
Mike says imagine if Ben had strings
attached to their jobs and be serious
about it mow the lawn and bag clippings
for the month if winter shovel the
driveway equals grocery money take the
trash to the street for the month equals
one date night oh and this was why guys
I had this argument even about date
night the key to a happy marriage is
date nights like what [__] do you
guys push do you think people in the
1600s were worried about a freaking date
night I guess we'll never
know like I am just so tired of this
Pander it's just it's just like
pandering to women 24/7 you deserve the
world you deserve a date night for
having one kid in public school but you
never hear staying in and cooking him
dinner you never hear that it's always
the date night what the women want trim
the trees brushes and weeds equals the
power bill fix one broken appliance or
leaky faucet equals one outfit change
oil in both vehicles nails done women
would lose their [__] the women should
be doing things for their husband and
for the house men build the houses women
create the homes with their nurturing
Natures see the pandering I don't even
believe women are more nurturing sorry
guys you have not given me one piece of
evidence that suggests we are more
nurturing you're starting to get a
reputation and until I see it I I none
of you guys' selfies with your kids are
going to convince me he's correct though
women are supposed to do chores around
the house they absolutely are and look
at guys I understand that women we are
not going to come in perfect most women
are not raised to be wives and mothers
we're not if you were born in the 1920s
maybe you were but it's been a hundred
years of feminist propaganda shoved down
our throats that is not typical
traditional women are rare I I've
interviewed thousands of women I
honestly think maybe one I could point
to and say she was traditional but as
long as there's light we got a chance
maybe if I really thought about it maybe
five they're they're not the norm but we
can't even admit what we are supposed to
do in a relationship it's like imagine
applying for or imagine trying out for
the NBA and you can't even admit that
you have to shoot a basket you know that
that's part of your duties and your
responsibilities as women and women we
just we just want everything handed to
us we just want these handouts and we
want a free ride for a lifetime you know
I have another controversial opinion
where I say women should work um and now
I'm not talking about women that have
five children and are State atome
mothers I'm saying the average woman
today has 1.5 children in her 30s and
the kids are in public public school
what are you doing all day I'm living my
best life go get a job so many women
just want to be absolutely useless and
be on Tik Tok all day and I just grew up
in a family that valued hard work you
were supposed to work hard and do
something and make something it it
wasn't even a man or a woman thing and
this isn't saying for women to be super
ambitious but I mean God give you gave
you a certain amount of talent so so
many of you guys are wasting it and have
done nothing with the talent that God
has given you poured into your children
poured into your husband poured into
freaking something don't pour over me
don't pour over
me I'll bring my glass to you but I see
I I interview these lazy entitled women
time and time again and it's just like a
waste of space really the other again
pandering pandering 101 I'm so tired of
the pandering The Reason Why Us young
women are so terrible I'll tell you why
we are absolutely terrible as young
women because older women have taught us
wrong older women have not told us what
they were supposed to they the older
women the women under the age of 70
typically because after the 60s that's
when the propaganda was in full force
full-fledged most of them were terrible
wives even if they didn't divorce on
paper many of them separated from their
husbands and many of them tried to
control their husbands for a life
lifetime we have terrible examples and
once you see this as a young woman you
cannot unsee it so Sharon Von stone is
an American actress and painter known
for primarily playing women of mystery
on film and television she became one of
the most popular sex symbol of the 1990s
she is the recipient of various
accolades including a prime time Emmy
Award a Golden Globe award and a
nomination for an Academy Award she
received a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame in 1995 and was named officer of
the order of the Arts and letters of
France in 2005 so there was a video
going viral of her just you know saying
the the norm I'm hot forever like why do
women have this obsession with being hot
forever we thought we would never die
you know and I see women my age just
investing in like all of this plastic
surgery a pound of all this stuff and
guys I I I don't even have a problem
with light plastic surgery I don't even
really have a problem with light minimal
stuff but you guys are just it's getting
crazy you guys are getting ridiculous oh
don't be ridiculous Andrea everybody
wants this and you show me examples of
women that are I don't know in the top 5
10% of beauty that they aged okay or a
little better than most as as a point of
oh oh women are hot they they stay hot
forever no you don't no woman is that
attractive after 35 she just becomes a
average a normal woman and before you
bring up JLo [__] do you look like JLo
none of you look like JLo so stop
bringing up these exceptional women that
you don't look like damn so there's a
60-year-old woman basically saying that
she is hot forever let's pull it up I'm
in my 60s people think that no one looks
at you anymore and the truth of the
matter is I I have just as many people
who want to sleep with me now as I ever
did there isn't that thing when you walk
in the room that every guy goes ooh
because you're not as easy as you were
when you were young and Men recognize
that's why they don't look at you as
much it's not because you're not as hot
you're not as easy to and you're not as
easy to get rid of and you're not as
easy to keep quiet you're not as easy to
dump afterwards you're not as easy to be
a side piece it's not that you're not as
hot you're hotter hotter because you're
more relaxed you're less concerned about
do I look great you know you look great
it's not cuz you're not as anything it's
just cuz you're not as easy oh easy prey
stop it get some help yeah that is the
stupidest thing I have heard and I'm so
tired of the stupidness like are women
this stupid and they're nodding along do
you have a picture of her when she was
younger so blessing just just now said
oh [__] this is her I haven't even seen
what she looks like yet but I already
know she was a hottie I already know
just based on his voice and the
attention that he just gave because men
naturally flock to beauty and it's so
funny God I so tired of the pandering
and you telling these women they look
younger they don't no you don't look
that young on the carnivore diet no you
don't look that young on the keto diet
no you didn't get some Botox and not
look older you guys all look old you
look your age you might look good for
your age but you still look your age and
these guys just Pander you cuz they're
nice none of these guys tell you the
truth they want to sleep with you even
at 60 they'll still want to sleep with
you but notice how she didn't say commit
you know just because you can get guys
to sleep with that's not even a
compliment that's not that's not an
accomplishment I see obese women get men
to sleep with them it doesn't mean
anything when you get older you get less
attractive men are not as interested and
the quality of men that you can get goes
down I don't I don't make the rules this
this is part of life and older women
used to actually tell the truth to
younger women so they didn't have to
live in delusion for a
lifetime I mean guys she was stunning
and this is why we call it the wall
because at some time and maybe women can
delay it a little bit with modern
technology but the Wall comes and the
wall hits you hard and if you don't have
the character to back it up you will be
invisible to people you know sweet kind
old grandmas they still get attention
from people but it's like the miserable
old ladies that nobody wants to deal
with anymore look at this wow she was
really beautiful back in the day look at
that go back wow she was stunning she
was like absolutely stunning wow so the
comment section weighs in I'm sure she
still does get a lot of male interest
but she's in the top 10% of her looks
for her age bracket with a with massive
social recognition and Novelty appeal
due to her former sex symbol status
totally not the average woman yeah and
that's the other thing people compare
the outcomes of a woman that looked like
that when most women will never look
like that ever
never
[Applause]
never and that's okay it is okay to be
normal it is okay to be average I don't
understand what women's gripe is with
just being an average chick you don't
have to be the top 10% of beauty you
know
and who's even to say that the women
that are beautiful are advantaged what
do you mean I know I know this is a
weird thought to have but you know if we
all Lo lose our looks roughly let's just
say 45 after 45 we hit metapa 50 I mean
who's truly advantaged the the women
that didn't have looks and had to work
on their character more or the women
that had it and are narcissistic
[__] at 60 like this the big one
Chris Mallet says she is capping and
they are all capping with her that is
why women are broken they just don't get
it they are their own worst enemies
Alexis Lancelot past or present you pick
well guys let me know in the comments
past or present who would you who would
you pick
right ow jeez what was that for it
doesn't matter it's in the
past yeah but it still hurts oh yes the
past can hurt but the way I see it you
can either run from it or learn from it
ah you see I I've talked a lot about how
women in 2023 are completely different
than women of other Generations I don't
even think the stats are really fair to
us I I almost think they're too good I
know you I I think the 50% divorce rate
will increase I don't say this in a
happy way I don't say it because I'm
happy about it I think that social media
has warped women's Brains so badly that
most women are not even capable of being
monogamous in getting attention from one
man that's to damn man I I think women
when they start at 12 12 13 years old
getting attention from all of these guys
online I think it is damn near
impossible for them to be monogamous I I
think it's impossible a modern marriage
is women still getting attention from
other men but maybe being sexually
exclusive to her husband that's a modern
marriage I've come to this conclusion
based on interviews and also based on
clips that I've seen of women talking
about this so I saw this woman talking
about her attention addiction from
Instagram would you ever start an only
and I was like how me me I like how
could you even ask me that and he
literally goes like you post things that
are basically like that what do you have
such judgment about it for and I was
sitting there like H and I really took a
step back I analyzed like the things
that I had been posting the presentence
that I had on social media and at the
time I was posting like seven stories a
day of myself I was so deep in it and I
had taken 3 days off of soci social
media not posting one story not posting
one photo of myself absolutely zero
attention and this is coming from
someone who I'm like I pride myself on
the fact that like I don't need male
attention I don't need attention from I
felt lonely not getting that attention I
can't even believe it I was not even
aware and I know this might sound so
silly to some people but when you're so
deep in it you have no idea the effect
that it's having even just the little
like hearts on social media that's like
a dope mean hit that was a moment where
I was like I have to change something
things stop it get some help that is
from a woman that's probably been on
social media since she was 12 13 some of
the kids even younger even younger it
warps your brain it makes you crazy you
know I I got social media in my teenage
years I was a little bit older now kids
are getting it at like s eight like kids
are growing up on iPad to the point
where 3 days off of social media I
actually think most women taking three
days off of social media would be be
crazy to them I I think that's the norm
not the exception so how do these women
go from getting all of this attention to
being monogamous I I don't think it's
likely I think it's mostly impossible I
think the modern relationship is going
to be the best ones are the woman is
sexually exclusive but she will still
receive attention and validation from
other men you will still see women and
and really I don't even want to say you
still see it you see it now I I see
wives and mothers and that that's why I
started the hashtag IEM challenge
because I these kids conservative
influencers would talk about how
conservative they are yet they would be
posting super sexual pictures while
married I I just couldn't even believe
it she belongs to the streets okay now
the comment section U weighs in and the
comment section you know what's funny
when women are are honest and actually
take a bit of accountability men are men
are actually nicer than you would think
so I applaud her for coming to that
realization a large percentage of women
will never have this Epiphany another
comment says she's cluing in this is how
Humanity evolves don't shame her while
it may seem trivial to reach this type
of self-awareness it will spread because
of her status and how many girls will be
fared from The Hollow Path yeah I'm not
too I've just seen so many chicks maybe
maybe I've turned into a pessimist I
don't know guys sometimes I don't know
when you're kidding I've seen so many
chicks like walk away and then come back
and do the same thing it's just yeah
okay T cozy says I I hope she does I
hope she does though they love two
things attention and being blissfully
unaware of their actions yeah I have
spoken time and time again how I believe
that women have a lot of jobs where they
are monetizing Beauty so I I think that
social media has changed the game for
young women we are able to monetize our
Beauty on social media and make money
this can either be done through of Um
this can also be done through sales
positions and you know office jobs but
social media has allowed women to make
an unprecedented amount of money at a
young age men too but it is easier for
the average woman to do it than the
average man and I have said that really
I I think a lot of times women are in
jobs and the men are doing all of the
work around them for them so there is a
video going viral of a woman broadcaster
let's pull it up hey y'all come look at
[Music]
this
I mean that's like the definition of
sitting and looking pretty and this is
why guys get pissed off because you know
the those guys probably had to bust
their butt to get there and then you
have these like 22-year-old chicks that
just walk in and they're handed these
positions because they're beautiful like
women privileged is invisible to those
who have it and women we have no idea
how much easier we have it in the world
this is in Corporate America this is
working in your hometown this is online
this is at ESPN we have it so much
easier because we are women and women
men just have a protective Instinct of
women and you know men there's power and
Beauty there is an un women throughout
history have it is not never been
uncommon for them to use their beauty to
gain power control and fluence but so
many times women and feminists will
complain about the pay when really I I
think that we're overpaid I I genuinely
do I think we're overpaid not underpaid
okay the saint Zone said she'll complain
about the wage Gap later JJ Crawley said
they'll blame the men for not getting
her
involved I've heard that before adz 331
they should just put a bikini on her
okay so our last topic today so many
women have no idea how terrible of wives
they are and I call them the wives in
sheep's clothing again we have a entire
society that tells us we're special
awesome amazing all the time and if a
guy tells you his grievances most women
you know I have a question to the ladies
can your guy tell you something that is
wrong maybe even do it in a way that we
would consider rude and would you give
him an attitude back or would you shut
up and listen shenise yeah your mouth is
H moving a lot like a rat yaa yaa yaa
yaa shut it place thank you shise so
many women the answer is if a guy tells
them any anything they will have to deal
with hell 4 days then he becomes
emotionally abusive then he's
emotionally abusive he's this he's that
he's that knowing this information guys
once you see this stuff and you can kind
of pick out men that are sort of in a
personal hell you can't really unsee it
a lot of times women think being
annoying and all of this stuff is cute
it's not cute and you guys are driving
your husbands insane let's pull it up
one the reasons why people don't
typically let me drink coffee and it's
not because I don't like it it's because
now my husband has to deal with me all
the way home and we still have another 3
and 1 half hours
left yeah look at him that man looks
like he's in imp personal hell he's
overweight not bullying I'm I'm just
pointing out she's overweight and really
you can tell she she's got the mentality
of a kid and okay when you're a young
woman that's one thing but once you get
married you start having children and
you pass on into that phase of your life
you're supposed to have a sense of
maturity and women really really don't
nowadays so the comment section weighs
in and says a grown woman thinking this
is cute or funny is wild and again this
is what happens when you spoil the women
this this is like that is a adult child
that's an adult child and it's not
uncommon when wives that are
deliberately annoying get left they
insist the man is selfish why are you
purposefully wanting to get your on your
husband's nerves sis Benjamin says he's
questioning everything I've seen that
face bro is on the edge I doubt they're
still together he seems stressed out
this stuff isn't cute and as women we
can't help where we start but I just
think as a collective we need to start
at least identifying what works and what
doesn't work and I really talk about
this stuff because it's very confusing
growing up in this day and age when
everybody is trying to get something
from you as a woman everybody's trying
to sell you something they are trying to
Virtue signal to you and they are also
trying to get sex half these guys so
they will Pander to you for a lifetime
and I just I'm just tired of it I'm
tired of seeing it so every episode we
read the top comment from the last
episode so today's top comment is
cheating isn't the problem to work
through cheating is a sign that the
relationship is already in trouble like
your favorite comment below make sure
you guys get yourself some merch we have
a bunch of new designs for you like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next
time